Thank you.
Okay, we're ready to go ahead with this last meeting, which we have here today regarding Committee of Conference bills.
This is HB 1665.
It is a continued session from yesterday, scheduled for 9 o'clock this morning.
We had made a motion at yesterday's meeting.
That was pulled back by myself.
I agreed to break and come back with some further recommendations.
So I will ask the Senate, are you coming back with some recommendations for us?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
So yes, we have a couple of recommendations, some of which I think we already agree upon.
As you recall, this bill had a 400 percent piece.
It had a reduction in the administrative percentage.
It had some reporting requirements, and it had some changes in the ADMA reimbursement.
What the Senate's change position will be is we'll agree to go to 425 on the percentage, leave the reduction in admin costs, leave the reporting requirements in the bill, and we'll agree to strike Section 5, which is the ADMA component that allowed for potential double dipping.
And that would be the Senate offer.
Okay, so let me also leave the phase-out grants and the phase-out.
So basically, we would be agreeing to the Senate version, moving the 400% to 425%, removing Section 5, which is the 0.15 FTE, and leaving everything else in place.
Senate position with two changes, 425% and strike Section 5.
So what we're going to do is take a brief caucus and we should be back in a few moments here thank you okay Thank you.
Thank you.
The response from the House is that we accept the terms proposed by the Senate to use the the Senate version to move percentage for the four-member family income to 425% of the poverty level and to eliminate Section 5 and the rest of the bill remains the same.
Excellent.
We're a yes.
And Valerie, you a yes?
Yes.
Glenn, you're a yes, and I'm a yes.
So we are done.
Thank you very much.
You'll get the conference report all drafted.
We'll get that report done, and that'll be in within the next half hour.
Right.
Do you want to submit the amendment change, or do you want us to go over and tell them?
It has to come from the chairman, and it's a House bill, so that's him.
Right.
Yes.
I tried to do one the other day, and it wasn't the chairman wasn't the chairman okay we'll get that done immediately thank you very much everybody Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, let's reconvene the committee conference on House Bill 1091.
Do we have the latest amendment?
And what is the number of the latest amendment?
We don We don't, Donna.
The one, the most recent one that I think.
2259?
We have 2259, which I think is the one we should work from.
Okay.
So, and I have a copy of that, and there's one change on page 12 that needs to be made.
Well, 2247 is pretty close, too, because it doesn't make those two changes on seven and whatever i think there were some myths that we had that donna and i can't yep poor courtney is gonna yeah it's going crazy so i think the two issues and one of them we've resolved, if I may.
Okay.
So let's start with the resolved one that's easy on page 12.
On line 23.
Which one are you reading off?
So I'm currently reading off of 2259.
And this is an easy one.
Page 12, line 23.
We're going to strike state senate, and we're going to move it up to following executive counsel on line 20.
Yep.
And that was for my request.
Correct.
And I concur with that.
So at least from the Senate side, we were on the same page and I think that was what the original House version was.
So that's an agreement.
The move it to line 20.
Yes.
Yeah, so that deadline an agreement.
Move it to line 20, you see?
Yes.
So that deadline would now apply to state senate as well as governor and executive council.
Thank you.
And then I think the last...
So just make sure I got that right.
Line 23, you want to strike state senate?
Yep.
Goes from here to there.
And move it to line 20.
Oh, and move it up.
Got it.
So the mandatory utilization of the system is an election year, an election cycle prior than what it is in the draft.
Okay.
so the second and that's the one I think we have to talk about, I did speak with Senator Gray yesterday, and then I spoke with Representative Lane.
We have one issue, and it's on page 7, bottom of the page, and the issue is line 31.
So right now, we define political advocacy organization on page 5, line 23.
It has its own definition.
The concern is that it is a type of political committee, but it is the only type of political committee that under current law, and I think we want to maintain current status, can make unlimited contribution.
So in order to maintain what is the current giving status, Representative Lane suggested that we say political advocacy organization unlimited.
And then 32, any other political committee or political party identifying that the previous one is in fact a political committee, but it's a political committee with a distinction.
Thank you.
political committee or political party, identifying that the previous one is in fact a political committee, but it's a political committee with a distinction.
Yeah.
Okay, so what's actually the proposed change?
Well, I think Senator Gray would like to see us do it differently, and that's where we have the one difference to resolve.
Well, the version that was in the Amendment 2247, I didn't have a problem with.
And what we've done here is we've moved around, but we're still at the 30, so...
Right.
I think that the way it is in this amendment, it's acceptable.
Because it has the 30,000 retained for any other, and then for the political advocacy.
And the only, if we put in any words, it would be any other not defined or something like that.
But I don't have a problem with the way it's even worded here.
Okay.
So if you don't have a problem with page seven of the current version, then I think that was it.
Senator Susi and I have had discussions over political conversations, I mean, political contributions and what the limits should be for years.
Yep.
So it's not new.
But this maintains what is the current status.
Correct.
It's the problem.
Then I think we.
I see that.
The image here.
Yep.
I think we have agreement.
So so 2259 as amended with the one change on page 12 is agreeable to the Senate 2259.
It's.
What?
Change on page 12 changes on the Senate.
They and that's it.
That's it.
Yeah.
Mr.
Chair.
Yeah.
Mr.
Chair.
Yeah.
I can't hear you.
I just gave you a copy with the markup so that you could see it.
No, no, not there.
Okay.
We're about version 15.
I do think we've got it right yeah it moves moves that yeah up to here that sentence that'll get you yeah table on page seven just want to i'd like to take a few more minutes and just scan through the rest of it.
Don't threaten me, Representative.
I'm kidding.
I have a reason to.
Recess for 5 or 10.
He doesn't need that 1.
No, I'm saying it's there, but I want.
Any political committee, except the political committee.
and it's good all right then uh Would you, Representative Lane, take this to OLS, tell them on my behalf to have a report drafted?
Yes, sir.
This way I don't.
Yes.
I got a lot of paper today, and I don't want to drop off the wrong one.
Really?
I can't imagine why you would have some.
Thank you very much.
Yes.
One question, which is 1091.
Everything's great.
Yeah.
So that means 534.
We've all just agreed to disagree.
Yes.
So that OLS knows we're not waiting on it.
For anything.
Yeah.
Correct.
OK.
This is the one version.
Perfect.
And while you're down there, Representative Lane, you want to let them know that there's going to be no report on Senate Bill 534.
At this point, I'm not sure they're worried about it.
They'll want to confirm it with Senator Gray.
Yeah, I'm sure they'll contact him.
Anything that crosses something off their list right now and narrows their focus, I think they're not going to ask a lot of questions.
All right.
We good?
Yes.
Thank you all very much.
And Senator Gray, I want to compliment your advocacy on the rights of movers across the state.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
It's 1230.
I'm opening up the committee of Conference on HP 1400, and then I'm going on a break.
We're waiting for the Senators as well as an amendment from OLS, so stand by.
Thank you.
all right welcome back um committee of conference hb 1400 um senator bradley senator perkins cuoca overnight we an amendment.
This isn't the complete amendment.
There's one other thing we're missing, but I at least want to go over the changes that we made.
I'm looking specifically at Amendment 2279S.
Line 3 on 2279S is the parking language we agreed to.
Shall not require more than 1.5 parking spaces per unit for studio and one bedroom units under 1,000 square feet that make requirements for workforce housing and shall not require more than 1.5 residential spaces per unit for multifamily developments of 10 units or more.
The second change we made, um, was adding the language that tenants' rights advocates and housing providers indicated they needed.
Specifically, line 22 says nothing in the section shall be construed to prevent the arrest and prosecution of a person or persons pursuant to RSA 635-1 or 635-2.
The third change that we made was under remedies under line 28.
Any tenant or landlord or non-rental owner shall have the right to seek relief from violation.
So by filing a petition district or county where the rental premises are located.
Now, if you look at the next page, we had advice from attorney layman to add on line one on page two, this language, nothing in this section shall be construed to extinguish any common law remedies, including self-help available to a non-rental owner.
That indicates that the non-rental owner shall have a right to do what they see fit as well.
the next change was on line six new subparagraph um it basically was a repeat of the um original language offered by senator parkinson bocca but the last line line 11 says nothing in section shall affect government governing or legislative bodies existing consultation process with the planning board um as.
And then lines 16 is the alternate parking solution that is part of Senator Perkins Cuoca's home to bus.
So that is also added.
And then the last line 29 on page two basically gets the parking language that we entered that we agreed on to speak to Senator Perkins Cuca's um uh alternate parking solution language so with that the only other change that we're looking at is the agreed upon sunset of the 79e provision of 10 years i think that's something that we chatted about yesterday um senator you can verify that for me if you'd like thank you chair yeah I just wanted to add to your very thorough summary that there's actually two sentences added in on lines 26 through 31 that are intended to make HB 1400 and what was formerly SB 538 speak to each other for the benefit of all of our municipalities and how they function and i agree the sunset is missing thank you okay any other comments from members of the committee senator bradley new language gonna go um i have it right my email right now okay it's getting printed right now it looks looks like the new language is...
Oh, okay.
Yep, right at the end, just the office relative office conversion zones is repealed...
In 10 years.
In 10 years, yep.
So that's the enabling municipalities to do the office conversions.
That's a 10-year-only provision.
All right, so we're going to go on a 3 minute break.
Make sure this works.
Choose.
There you go.
What's that?
Oh, thanks.
Thank you.
okay so we are back so i'm looking at amendment number 2024 2286 s um the only other change as indicated is on line or page 2 line 33 repeals the 79e office conversion zone um at at 2035.
so with that i'll um take a final vote to approve the committee of conference so we'll move i'll move this let's see i think actually you're moving to the senate position with these changes Thank you.
Let's see, I think actually you're moving to a seat to the Senate position with these changes.
So that's my motion.
House received to the Senate position with the changes in 2286s.
I second that motion to a seat to the Senate version with amendment number 2286s.
All right, so take a vote all those in favor opposed none okay so we're four to zero in favor so um i will go to ols and get this report undrafted and you have to sign off by four o'clock so please indicate to senator gannon to get that done for us i'll replace him if he'd be okay well thank you very much thank you very much i have to say it was a really good job awesome Thank you.
Thank you.